Mm,
I
think it's okay to start my analysis of
Guillermo del Toro's,
Pan's labyrinth with a spoiler Ofelia
the main character.
She dies at the end.
I feel fine doing that because del Toro
does the exact same thing with his
movie.
The first shot of Pan's labyrinth is the
ending and it's also the first way in
which deltoro complicates that epic,
but before we get into that,
a few things about fairytales,
but for most of us,
the authoritative source for fairytales
is Walt Disney and that's no accident.
Disney set out to claim that authority
when he made films like snow,
White Cinderella,
sleeping beauty by adapting folktales in
the public domain and copywriting the
adaptations still because film was a
relatively new medium.
Capturing the authority he wanted
require Disney to remain faithful to the
original versions of these stories
popularized by Charles perrow and the
brothers Grimm.
He made the transition from print to
cinema as smooth as possible for the
audience even going so far as to begin
his movies.
With the opening of a book,
Disney was smart.
His films are now regarded as classics,
and yet by remaining so faithful to the
stories 19th century antecedents,
he inherited and furthered their 19th
century morality,
a conservative patriarchal value system
in which the prince always comes to save
the helpless heroin,
a value system that was antiquated.
Even then in this way,
Disney limited the kinds of things a
fairytale can do in Pan's labyrinth.
Guillermo del Toro attempts to explode
these limitations and he does so by
recontextualizing.
These stories,
instead of pulling from a single
authoritative source,
del Toro pulls from a huge number of
sources,
giving none precedence over the others
and letting them all play against one
another to create meaning.
The film tells the story of the little
girl Ofelia and her mother Carmen,
as they go to live with the hyper
fascist to captain vidal.
Five years after the Spanish civil war,
the Dallas trying to sniff out the last
remnants of rebellion in the mountains,
awaiting his child's birth by Carmen.
While Ofelia becomes ensnared in a
magical quest after a fond tells her
that she is the lost princess of an
underground realm.
From here,
the story spins out into two parallel
narratives,
the magical quest and the political
drama.
Crucially,
neither of these narratives becomes
reducible to the other.
Del Toro makes a point of this by
entwining them in ways that makes any
totalizing explanation problematic.
At the end of the film,
for example,
we get seems to be the nail in the
coffin for the magical quest,
but dol approaches Ofelia speaking with
the font and when the camera cuts to his
point of view,
the font is not there.
This appears to be solid evidence for
those who read Ofelia's quest as a
coping mechanism for her set life,
but if we back up,
we can see how Deltoro complicates that
reading by remembering that the dol has
just been drugged with a heavy dose of
sleeping medication.
In other stories,
drug induced hallucinations are used to
explain a way why people see the
supernatural,
but in Pan's labyrinth,
it's the opposite.
Del Toro uses the device to destabilize
our trust in Captain v Dot Dallas point
of view here and elsewhere.
The film refuses to obey our desire for
an all encompassing explanation.
Of course,
disobedience is a major theme in this
film
I see,
whereas in many fairytales,
disobedience is the act that sets the
story in motion here.
Disobedience is framed as a vital and
important quality.
There's the disobedience of the rebels
who seek to free Spain from the grip of
fascism,
the disobedience of Mercedes,
who works with the rebels,
and of course the disobedience of Ofelia
who by turns questions and disregards
the commands of her mother,
the captain and the font,
but the most effective and I think
impressive disobedience here is that
displayed within the very text of the
movie,
and this is where del Toro's intense
referencing comes into play.
The name of the game here is
multiplicity,
undermining a single authoritarian
master narrative like those champion by
the dol and fascism in general by
setting up a network of inter texts that
make meaning a matter of choice.
I think of all the linking references in
the pale man scene,
for example,
you have the ogre himself nodding to
other child eating ogres and other
mythologies like krampus.
It also refers to the Greek Titan
Kronos,
who devoured his god.
Children in order to like fascist Spain,
keep the young from replacing them and
coming into their own.
Also,
it should be noted that Kronos is the
title of Del Toro's first film,
one of many things that links his body
of work together.
The table itself links back to the
banquet scene earlier in the film,
putting the Pale man in the same
position as the Dell who will go on to
kill a child.
The pile of shoes link forward and we'll
go on to recontextualize Ofelia's red
shoes itself,
a link to the wizard of Oz and the 1948
film by Powell and Pressburger
recontextualize as images reminiscent of
the piles of clothes from Nazi
concentration camps and the scene itself
functions as a metaphor for how beauty,
like say,
the beauty of old fairytales can enchant
us into certain lines and ways of
thinking that may not be in our
interest.
Here you have constructed a vast network
of citation that reaches elsewhere in
the film and outside of it.
The lines of that network are for the
viewers to follow as they see fit.
Del Toro laces these references together
with camera work and editing to achieve
a narrative momentum that's undeniable
when you watch his movies.
It was the purpose of the doll like it
is the purpose of all authoritarian
regimes or patriarchal moralistic
fairytales to limit the number and kinds
of stories that can be told from a set
of facts or events.
Indeed limited to one story.
The only thing for us is to disobey you.
In old fairytales.
The stories were closed out in contained
by two words.
The end adult touros genius is to use
perhaps this most formulaic genre of all
and disobey our expectations and how it
should unfold and how it should end.
The rebels capture and kill the doll,
but Spain will continue under
authoritarian dictatorship for 30 years.
Ophelia is murdered,
but completes her quest and returns to
the underground realm.
Or you can read that as a poetic ending
to a sad story,
but happy ending to a fairytale or
Ophelia's final choice of the story she
wants to tell for and about herself.
Of course,
she doesn't have
to choose at all.
No single story could contain her for
even when she returned to the world of
magic,
it has said she left small traces of her
time on earth,
visible to those who know where
and how to look.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching.
Pan's labyrinth has been one of my
favorite movies since I saw it in
theaters,
so this was just a blast to make.
If this is the type of content that you
don't think you're seeing anywhere else
on,
on youtube or the Internet,
you can support this channel by pledging
to my patreon page right here.
Everything helps.
You guys have been amazing with that and
it really is what makes this channel
possible and keeps it going.
So I'm going to Paris for the next
couple weeks.
I might miss a week.
I'm talking to you from the past right
now,
but if I don't see you next Wednesday,
I'll see you the Wednesday after that.